prende tutti ragazzi pervenute questo
video sono fa vj che oggi siamo in un
gioco dove c'è un ospedale non era
allegro chirurgo
credetemi questo è sicuro come se non
bastasse ovviamente colloquio stripped
quindi è una cosa molto carina
sì che figo mi mancasse sensazioni che
bello sì in pieno luglio questo caldo
siamo alle hawaii ma non era così la
stanza dell'hotel che ho prenotato lo
portiamo mind box presence sta minchia
che cosa prese c'è scritto c'è scritto
stronzo chi legge che la roba bello non
ama si capisce conto tranquillo e ho
studiato 20 anni sta lingua quindi
perfetto c'è scritto che le banane al
supermercato ragazzi sono scadute non
dovete prenderle questo c'è scritto
fidatevi di uno zio favi che qua
funziona tutto dove siamo alla madonna
che portò ora mi chiama costa
catapecchia che ciò io cazzo si sta
muovendo lui lega madonna che brutto zio
non uscire così di notte dai e portava
siamo in fra l'altro horror dove ci
troviamo in un ospedale con locus lift
perché ci sono dei funghi perché ci sono
dei funghi sul ma che cazzo me ne frega
dei funghi non lo hai capito sta roba le
fughe ma chi se ne fotte andiamo avanti
ma qualcuno ha scritto il bagnoschiuma
si trova nel reparto bagnoschiuma
perfetto ma che figo regalo assurdo
guardala colloquio per cosa non ho mai
provato quel tipo ragazzi però è un figo
e non è che possiamo dire altro
comunque a parte la televisione che
parla aramaico francese grazie succhiami
le palle non è per essere scortesi e per
cortesia però non apriamo queste porte
mentre sto giocando grazie fa lui
ragazzi fa tutto lui
esplorando gli ascensori quante cose che
impari non ti permettere che tutto ho
detto non ti devi permettere si apre mi
trovo a questa un anti lancio tutto si
uscita uscita bruttissima è lo stesso
piano di prima sono al buio non sa chi
sei tu sono fa vj sono uscito da una
stanza o rompe cos'era questo rumore qua
no al rompete i [ __ ] perchè giuro
che chiamo l'infermiere vi faccio fare
siringhe cose di qua io non sarei che
dove sta andando
[Musica]
porca la [ __ ] trottola eva bella
mara sei tu eri sporca di sangue zia
trova una lavanderia affidati che è
meglio e il cielo quello non so non
m'interessa mandanda volte buio non vedo
un caso mi è cascato l'iphone non mi è
cascato un cane che cosa è successo
e va bene che ho già capito che tanto
non ne vedo
[ __ ] tu e tua madre alle porte di
tutto il mondo avvertire prima di aprire
no e così proprio a cazzola mentre vado
avanti di qua io non ho ancora capito
dove sta andando la quale l'obiettivo
visto gioco a parte andare in giro
ragazzi c'è scritto uscita è ma siete
stronzi e perdendo che di qua ci sia
all'uscita perché c'è scritto cazzo
uscita quindi non è che mi interessa
piano piano che gioca se mi spunta
qualcosa madonna d'ischia e ascolta e
c'è riuscita di quadro io l'ho visto
l'uscita vasca [ __ ] [ __ ] bastarda e
papà che avevamo scritto nella bibbia
queste cose forse credo sì sì sì va beh
certo del successo che ha terminato dove
siamo
io ho seguito solo una scritta con
scritto uscita
basta un fatto niente è l'uscita non
l'ho trovata manco a pagarlo di siamo
davanti ai cancelli salute salute di
nuovo zia hai rotto il cazzo zia che chi
sta scoraggiando teletubbies poi non
sono i teletubbies lega non sono i
telethon qualcuno che pulisca questi
posti per cortesia
almeno quando ci passo io
premesso samara uscita madonna gli
schiaffi si trova un'altra scritta
uscita e non esco ti giuro che ti esco
la famiglia giorno taylor swift sei tu
gag meno e noi bambini non si toccano i
bambini giochino lega non si toccano
chiama al telefono azzurro che bel
quadro in questa roba non finisce non mi
interessa perché sono molto cortese via
porta qualcuno s'è appena preso una
siringa ragazzi non so chi è e deve aver
fatto un gran male a quanto samara
facciamo due conti e non è che possiamo
andare avanti
i cori e io ti seguo perché non è una
cosa normale capisci se siamo in un
gioco oro tu fai le cose se mi spunta
qualcosa lancio questo questo preso non
lo sa nemmeno lo sto vedendo c'è una
porta bruttissima che dio santo che si è
aperta ovviamente al sabah shannon i
sensori ste porte che si aprono solo ma
non lo so io vado avanti comunque a
porta o non forte ma sento rumori di
catene e una donna che geme sarà mica
sadomaso e ragazzi a si sente orgasmi
perfetto
non importa non mi interessa non voglio
neanche saperlo e la madonna che
belletti non lo prendi lei che ha
soprattutto andando in servizio senti
hai pagati da
dall'inizio del gioco che continua a
vedere samara i luoghi bruttissimi st
porta sia aperta si sia aperto si sta
muovendo sparato non sono io e non c è
la serie d non lo shock giorno sei tu no
no no no mi hai lanciato una sedia non
si perfetto di qua chi è che ha fatto
cadere la bottiglia di te alla pesca lui
ci sono due ore che entrò in stanza
cazzo senza motivo proprio così per me
essere da o chiede o finalmente una
stanza bolzan [ __ ] tranquilli
nessuno vi disturbano e la madonna c'è
il pene di rocco siffredi ci andiamo un
po più piano con queste ragazze perché
non è possibile
niente di nuovo regala tranquilli e vado
di sicuro non indietro sorridi tu noi
tanti milioni ma non c'è niente tutti ma
ridere e ridicoli ma si ride e poi mi
fate ridere anche a me per fare non fa
ridere volta zia ridiamo meno e
camminiamo libro è ecco fa 105 andata
eni e le porte continuano ad aprirsi di
mortacci della vostra famiglia ancora
scarpa basta stess cara amica dove sta
andando nell'entroterra però che
l'inferno non sia più basso di così
perché mica tra posto umbre in cina c'è
un motivo che samara samaras in rossa
sporca di riciclo a riciclo in faccia al
ciclone marquinhos fotocamere sta
correndo lui e regalo sta correndo lui
non faccio sto facendo assolutamente
niente
mara sei una gnocca ok ok ascoltami
passiamo da kiko adesso che usciamo ti
faccio un paio di trucchi ti faccia
diagnosi si può andare corrie lurido
stronzo
stavo scommesso la vita dove sono ciao
zia giochiamo al pala schiaccia 7
qualcosa mi ha preso e appreso mi sta
trascinando non so dorica iva le banane
e project manager il finale che sono
stato stuprato da una donna non truccata
e finito veramente così ma che ove ma
[ __ ]
io mi sto rifiutando di giocare a sta
roba rendetevi conto del disagio che
cazzo mi devo dire è stato carino
complimenti dite a quella donna di
rifarsi un attimino la faccia ragazzi
madonna mentre loculo swift costo caldo
e tipo come mettere non terra non sifoni
in faccia
voi non avete visto niente ragazzi è
stato un horror della madonna della
serie apriamo e chiudiamo le porte a
cazzo lo chiamerei possibilmente non
aprire quella porta ma l'abbiamo aperto
guardi i ragazzi per ogni mi piace a
video samara si rifarà un po la faccia
la mattina con quello che hai bisogno
ragazzi spero che ai video vi sia
piaciuto e come al solito se video è
piaciuta stato punito mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che cosa ne divido
tra descrizione sarà se dovessi discrete
i cibi da 1 posto nido della ragazza